Sentinels were once North America's most
beloved valorant team I'm on tense side
I want to see him play longer with this
roster they were the best team in the
world and they looked Unstoppable tens
is there now able to help Dapper as that
wall goes down and this is beautiful
just enough time bought there by that
cage and now Shazam swings in Sentinels
are looking fantastic but somewhere
along the way
everything went wrong
Shazam is there tens they're all looking
for it no opportunities being found is
traded out again yeah he's there it's
all launches up it's still it's done
with
Dapper it's your time to shine right
about now it's all on you buddy
surrounded all fronts it's
up there are only three players standing
between the guard and a 13-1 win on
icebox and a 2-0 sweep
of this playoff tournament and as
quickly as it started it ended
Sentinels are still in his favorite team
but we had to ask what happened to
valerian's First champions
Sentinels were on top of n a last year
and now I don't think you can say the
same I don't think it was people being
uncomfortable I think that no matter the
agents we played we failed uh like the
most basic level tens has to be playing
in God form for this team to have a
chance and that is horribly worrying
there's no way to describe the Humana
[__] and Hate
that I'm getting it is happening before
our eyes it is emphatically the end for
sentinel's dominance in North America it
is emphatically the end
[Music]
and now that they've signed shroud what
does the future hold for Sentinels
[Music]
hey folks before we get the video I want
to ask you to please sub to the channel
if you haven't done it yet and please
turn on notifications and once you've
done that you can head over to twitch.tv
score Esports and follow us there
because we are streaming all the time
now and you don't want to miss a stream
okay so Sentinels were valerian's first
ever International Champions Magnums in
the Smoky attention oh my god well
magnum's got no HP not like like this
Sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it Sentinels of the masses
to Reykjavik Champions but even before
their first big win when valerian's
competitive scene was still brand new
Sentinels were already far ahead of the
competition to be able to qualify
already on the champion stage getting
all the points winning Masters one
winning Masters two they're on fire so
far tens was the team's brightest star
but Tans and Company holding on but the
response from Cloud9 has been Swift as
well but this it's gonna go all the way
for the Yanks you have to be kidding me
Shazam was The Mastermind behind
sentinel's best strats Shazam is the one
to dissect their opponents and be able
to take anyone down right now and
they're looking good to try to finish
this one Shazam has to go to the
to the screen on his first
[Applause]
ly done that SEC had the versatility to
make pretty much any situation work
doubled up here in lumps and that's
gonna be the double swing but the timing
of sick it's a bit missed time still he
gets two watts is that
another nade yep pushes him off he got
that one back pretty quickly pushing all
the way down short he knows the players
there will it be the ace for him
close the pouring hands right around the
corner Dapper was in a reverent clutch
God who could consistently back up his
disrespect and uh looks like he's gonna
find it on the flank and go be spotted
now as well no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I can't believe you've done
this in the cram final
and finally there were zombs one of the
best controller players in the game high
angle low angle he's trying to clear all
the other potentials and now he's
decided right this has to be at this
where they're gonna be upstairs
that spray couldn't have been better
together Sentinels dominated valorant
this is a team that's like maybe the
most adaptive team in the business which
is makes them extremely resilient
against any style of play that baloran
has to offer all five of those players
were insane fraggers but when it really
comes down to when they were actually
facing team to team from week to week
ended up coming down simply to their
preparation and how dedicated they
actually were to changing how they
approached when you didn't have that
many agents out uh in the game it was a
little bit easier for you to be like
okay well if I'm gonna try to flash the
retake it to the site or it's not gonna
be like a cosmic divide or gravity well
or something like that too so it's just
like straight up we're gonna try to get
in and we can just fight it out and they
were really really good at that actually
for for Sentinels and of course when you
have that on top of their aim then it
was just normal that they were going to
be the best team in the world between
sentinel's Reykjavik Triumph and their
na Victory Tour afterwards it looked
like they were going to be valorin's
first dynasty all they had to do was
keep winning but the Sentinels era was
about to come to an end
Sentinels moving together through garage
sick and Dapper the players that need to
clutch this out and they've both had
their rounds Dapper in this one alone
has been fantastic but there's no
utility to play with here Tom it's all
down to aim duels on both sides of the
coin
the time is so low they need to make a
move they need to find a kill soon find
some space sick is taken down it's all
up to Dapper he's going in for the stick
halfway at least ready to take the fight
up above and Cole dementia shut down
he's almost gone but they push at just
the right moment 13 to 11 G2 have won
the series and Sentinels are dethroned
at long last G2 the kings are back and
this is their Town truly
unbelievable we have never seen this
team lose on land and finally someone
has managed to take them down Sentinels
went into Masters Berlin with High Hopes
but G2 quickly handed them their first
ever International loss and then fellow
North Americans team Envy sent Sentinels
packing in the quarterfinals found a
little bit of a cleaner success story
here that's a follow-up and a half
crashes we saw him on the last map but
unable to Kindle the complete picture of
fire oh yeah alive he knows where you're
at as well zom's that frenzy zombies has
posted on this one he's checking no way
you're Envy trying to maybe force him
away from a couple of angles here but
crashes way ahead of it eats the flash
though so does Victor now there's
problems one left one dry what can
Victor do in this
way
now they try and bite the time the flash
comes in it doesn't quite find what they
wanted yay still trying to dip between
CT I'm watching that drop down Shazam is
there tens they're all looking for it no
opportunities being found is traded out
again yeah he said it's all on Shazam
it's over it's done with they say when
you come for the king you best not miss
an Envy they didn't Sentinels
you don't often get to see it
made to look human the First Slice of
blood came towards him earlier in this
tournament by a European team and now
the North American Brothers
I've got one step further the loss was
obviously disappointing but at that
point it was just one tournament it was
impossible to say where the team would
go from there still people had all kinds
of theories about why the gods of
valorant fell so early from cracking
under the pressure to just making bad
in-game decisions but Sentinels had no
doubt that they could make a comeback a
champions last Thursday Berlin obviously
was our worst placing as a team this
year but I think about the thing that
defined us as a team is how we handled
losses and I think that we handled that
pretty well from the time between
Masters three and now we haven't played
the official match there's like no
complacency here we knew that when we
came into Europe that we were going to
[__] out scrims as much as we can and
I'm feeling really confident
unfortunately confidence could only take
Sentinels so far hi poke are we about to
see Santos potentially sent home
by crew and it all comes down to this 12
to 11 1 team beckoning for greatness and
they're gonna Flash
oh my God
Dapper it's your time to shine right
about now it's all on you buddy
surrounded all fronted God it's done
with it oh my [__] god no [__]
away man no expectations oh my God no
one would have said this would have been
the outcome no one in their right mind
would have said that Sentinels run and
valorant champions finished in the group
stage a shocking result from a team that
just a few short months ago looked
superhuman dude my heart hurts For Tons
I believe he's super sad
I know we lost but like or people are
saying like stuff about certain agents
but I didn't feel uncomfortable with a
roll-ons guy I feel like it fell apart
in our communication and like teamwork
you know I don't think it was people
being uncomfortable I think that no
matter the agents we played we failed uh
like the the most basic level it sucks
we were all sad dude I could tell it
affected the guys everyone really cared
as much as people think we don't care
for the narrative that n a doesn't care
or care about streams or whatever I
promise like I know our team tried
really [__] hard and sadly things
were about to get even worse
Sentinels 2022 didn't exactly start off
on a high note Sentinels scraped by I
felt like through the group stage a lot
of their early matches 2-1 versus NRG
versus Knights versus rise teams you
would put them above and then they lost
optic they got two owed by version one
Sentinels were on top of n a last year
and now I don't think you can say the
same new teams have arrived to replace
them and the guard are certainly doing
it here on icebox
not done quite yet but they can taste it
Victory just on the other side
and there are only three players make
that two standing between the guard and
a 13-1 win on icebox and a 2-0 sweep of
Sentinels in the opening round of this
playoff tournament and as quickly as it
started it ended they went oh and two
during n a stage one Challengers
playoffs benched zombs and for the first
time in the team's history failed to
qualify for an International Event I
feel like we've been talking about this
for a while but people have been blowing
it off you know send those fans are like
no you just the analyst desk invented a
narrative if Sentinels are just going to
bounce back it's the same as it was last
year but it is happening before our eyes
it is emphatically the end for
sentinel's dominance in North America it
is emphatically the end no one puts more
effort in the team than I do
yeah people think I I don't care I have
an ego because I don't respond to
Twitter criticism allowing us to run
yeah and Arena everyone had the same
question on their minds what happened to
Sentinels how did they go from the best
team in the world to one of the worst
teams in n a well there are a lot of
reasons they're in an environment in
North America where we've seen so many
teams pop out of basically nowhere the
guard ghost Evil Geniuses this scene is
made for those that want overnight
success and Sentinels they talk about
how it's so hard to be in this
environment well they also have the same
exact opportunity to make that type of
success to take that type of tempo when
Astra came out and then a lot of teams
started using Astra and even Phoenix
starting to get it a little bit a little
bit more of a drop in terms of of
character usage because even Skye came
out and then you could kind of do some
better things with Sky than you can do
with Phoenix with with the flashes but
sandals were really adamant to still
want to stick to to try to test it in
true of what Sentinels were known for
which team screams the most that you
could easily say looks like the guard's
starting to step out but I think all
this man really yeah
no bias right you actually think so I
actually think it's uh definitely I know
who screams the least I'm not gonna say
anything
oh
is it really sensitive I thought it was
just a meme Sentinels squeak through the
na open qualifiers to make it into stage
two Challengers despite adding conteki
to the roster to replace zombs and
bringing raucous on as a head coach full
time some people suggested that
Sentinels were too stubborn to adapt to
valor's ever-changing meta others blame
the team's overconfidence and still
others blamed individual team and staff
members tens wasn't playing well enough
raucous wasn't a good enough coach
Shazam was streaming too much the list
of excuses goes on and on I didn't
stream for like a leak and I got the
most [__] for streaming that I've ever
gotten that's how I know I can't win
there's no way to describe the Humana
[__] and Hate
uh I'm getting I'm pretty convinced that
no normal player would be able to handle
this whatever the reason outside of a
few standout performances by individual
players Sentinels took a huge tumble and
we're now officially one of the lowest
ranked tier one Valor teams in North
America and the narrative recently has
been tens needs to pop off in order for
Sentinels to win they really rely on
their star player tennis has to be
playing in God form for this team to
have a chance and that is horribly
worrying the rest of the team needs to
step up as well the straightforward aim
focused puggy style of play that once
got Sentinels to the top no longer cut
it the team looked like they lacked
cohesion it didn't seem like they spent
enough time developing and practicing
new strategies and relying on tens to
pop off every single map was holding
Sentinels back from making any real
progress but truthfully it also seemed
like Sentinels hit a streak of some
really bad luck outside of the game tens
got covet and sake was an remains out
indefinitely due to a family emergency
forcing raucous and another stand-in
Danny to sub in to varying degrees of
success you've got to expect that FNS
could be holding here surely I don't
think the stone kills the Drone
you gotta noted as a potential in the
crossfire is laid down
flexor easy peasy Victor's also just
gonna be flanking at the same time
that's going to be the Viper's bit drop
down onto the side it's a bit of chaos
crashes just works his way into it the
snake bite dropped down there was
vulnerability apply for tapa walking
forwards
heads found now oh he's just trying to
stick the plant but no one's covering
but the ocean away yeah and Becky works
his way into the pit just Dapper left
alone and this is going to be match
point
massive task ahead of him not enough
yeah that but yeah it just I honestly
Sue it it wasn't a fair fight we kind of
knew that going into it I mean look at
this from tense in heaven dashes across
Marshall in hand boom Oh unlucky
straight in and unfortunately not quite
going to work there definitely feels
like uh Sentinels have have got their
their filler The Whimsy today seeing
that respect shown
thunder so weak
[Applause]
oh my God
oh my not the dog not the dog not the
dog to finish it
well uh stage two looking like it might
be ending in emphatic fashion here for
Sentinels in stage two Challengers
Sentinels finished at the bottom of
their group after a final 2-0 lost to
Cloud 9 Sentinels had nothing left but
the n a last chance qualifier and even
that wasn't a guarantee even the teams
that beat Sentinels had to acknowledge
that they weren't facing the former
Champions at their Peak I'm not gonna
lie it was kind of like a really boring
series I'm not saying that because like
I'm not saying that like oh
we're so much better so it's like boring
I'm saying it was kind of like found it
was kind of like we knew they were like
really like handicapped because of the
two subs so like it kind of sucks not
playing people when they're at their
best you know so luckily for Sentinels
there was a team that managed to do even
worse than them which gave Sentinels a
spot in the last chance qualifier bro
Sentinels are gonna qualify for lcq you
may be able to beat them down but you
can't keep them out the guard was no flu
can't keep him out and that's why
they're the [__] best we'll be back
don't don't you don't you worry your
little heart
we'll be back
the last chance qualifier is exactly
that for Sentinels it is their last
chance to make it to Champions and turn
around the toxic narrative that's been
developing around the team Sentinels
they haven't had a coaching staff they
haven't had enough time really I think
dedicated to themselves to really focus
on being creative on changing the way
that valorent is played it's one last
chance they could put all five of their
brains into one go I think lcq is that
chance to finally see those comp changes
in the end the the fan base that hates
Sentinels as much as the fanbase that
love Sentinels even the ones that hate
deep down inside actually do love
Sentinels so I think it's just nothing
but a positive thing for the for the org
and for the team and to make things even
more complicated just a month before the
lcq Sentinels announced who was
officially Gonna Stand in for sick
shroud I'm back baby I'm back what's up
teammate I'm gonna be playing for the
lcq I'll be there
I will be in the lcq I have a lot of
grinding to do catch myself up but hey
I'm not alone so Sentinels also picked
up zelsus to round out their lcq roster
and they got one of the best analysts in
valorin on their staff needless to say
they're taking the last chance very
seriously but everyone is talking about
shroud and sure people say the Shroud is
one of the greatest first person shooter
Gamers of all time but he hasn't played
a professional game of anything in four
years no one knows how this insane
gamble is gonna play out so now after
all of that where does this leave
Sentinels fans the Die Hard n a homers
who watch their Idols rise to the very
top and crash to the absolute bottom in
just one year well they still have hope
because Sentinels know what they need to
work on and they're determined to do
better bootcam Reddit is finally happy
yeah Sentinels tweeted or boot camping
I'm just gonna be playing like 24 7
probably at the boot camp the real
practice is gonna art at boot camp but
yeah we've kind of started scrubbing and
getting accustomed to things so how's it
became coins for how do you think I'll
do it I mean we're doing really well
we're progressing really fast we're
gaining the chem really quick just one
map at a time take it one map at a time
the future of valorent as a whole is up
in the air right now beyond the lcq and
champions franchising is on the horizon
and Sentinels are gonna need to step it
up if they want to enter the new era of
valorent as more than just fallen heroes
but no matter what comes next Sentinels
will have always been the first the
first to be the best the first to be the
biggest the first to be everyone's
favorites they're already a huge part of
valor in history and maybe they can be
the ones who write its next chapter
foreign
[Music]